i am so lucky how many kids in the world
would pay to be doing this right now
starring in one of the biggest
franchises of all time
certainly has its moments the cast of
the massively popular harry potter
franchise spent over 10 years on set
so you'd be fair to assume that the
actors made some treasured memories
while filming
from getting to dance with dame maggie
smith two stage diving at the yule ball
and even exploding toilets these are the
wizarding cast favorite onset moments
give everyone the space to kind of try
and do a good job i think
wright enjoyed her first time filming a
scene at the iconic platform nine and
three quarters
while it was an overwhelming experience
at first good luck
wright would later state it was so
welcoming and i was made to feel like i
knew what i was doing
and not patronized and i think that was
a good thing for all of us
wright also brought up the room of
requirements scene in the order of the
phoenix
initially a claustrophobic experience
but it became something that she really
enjoyed
but i think that's why i like it because
i think it was like such a specific time
when everyone was just like annoying
teenagers
carter's favorite scene on set wasn't
necessarily playing bellatrix per
se she highlighted that this sequence
where she is playing hermione disguised
as bellatrix as her favorite scene to
film
i wish to enter my vault rather than put
emma watson in a hell of a lot of makeup
they just said now you go act like
hermione that was fun
because i always wanted to be hermione i
was looking at dan and rupert and they
were treating me as if i was 17.
david really wanted me heavily involved
in helping helena
really become me just like carter one of
watson's favorite scenes to film was the
gringotts set piece
we got to work together with her um
playing me essentially
and we had so much fun watson has also
said that her favorite movie was the
first one
because everything was new and
everything being a novelty
is very exciting she also said that
making the last film was an amazing
process as she was given more to do
and even got to perform her own stunt
work what a good
harry do you think this mirror shows the
future
grint has said that his favorite moment
while filming the franchise was his very
first day on set
grint had never actually been on a film
set before and didn't necessarily know
how movies were made
and was surprised to learn that they
were already filming the last scene of
the film
he claimed that everything just felt so
new and exciting to him
it was just incredible it was the most
amazing thing i've ever seen in my life
felton has stated that he didn't feel he
got his true chance to shine
until the half-blood prince he singled
out the bathroom battle between draco
and harry as his favorite scene to film
while most wand battles require cgi
felton revealed that the production team
went the extra mile for this particular
scene
in this case they drink the whole
bathroom with explosives so
every time you give a little flick
something would blow up
ivana lynch's favorite moment from the
films was the wizard wedding from
deathly hallows part 1 which was quite
the experience to film
you see in the background all these
wizards dancing i don't know
i've never been to a wizard wedding but
it was pretty cool
another and more personal memory was
when she first met jk rowling in person
she just walked into the room and i
didn't register that it was her
because you think she's just this
amazingly talented super famous
legendary writer but she's so small in
real life
she's just a normal lady and i was like
how could all this come from one person
it's just got the most amazing
atmosphere
and it's brilliant it's so cool
radcliffe's favorite movie is the order
of the phoenix which holds a special
place in his heart
especially because of the relationship
between harry and sirius
they also shared excellent chemistry
off-screen one moment that has stuck out
to him was when gary oldman taught him
how to play come together on the bass
guitar
i was learning at the time and he also
plays bass so like i had a bass lesson
from gary oldman one morning that was
that was pretty great who wouldn't want
to celebrate their birthday at hogwarts
alongside the wizarding cast
that's exactly what happened with devin
murray who said that he celebrated his
11th
through 22nd birthdays on the sets of
all eight films
murray has said that his 11th birthday
celebration was his favorite
specifically when filming a scene set in
professor flitwick's levitation class
murray stated that producer david heyman
brought in a huge chocolate cake and
showered him with gifts
he even got to keep the feather he blew
up in the scene they shot that day
welcome to your first flying lesson
matthew lewis says that his favorite
scene as neville was the flying lesson
sequence from the first film
which took place during the first week
of filming while initially
nervous for the scene director chris
columbus tempered those fears
he put me at ease and made me relax and
it ended up being the most fantastic
week
i remember being very excited for the
next six months or so
little did i know that it would go on
for another decade
from this day forth you put your faith
in me one of ray fein's favorite moments
he filmed came from the battle in
deathly hallows part 2.
and i love shooting the death duel that
was cool with daniel
in the in the big courtyard that was
epic another one of his favorite moments
on set
actually happened off camera son of the
script supervisor
was sitting he was about five or six and
i just walked past in my voldemort
makeup and he just burst into tears
sir michael gambin said the yule ball
scene from goblet of fire was a favorite
of his
where he shared a dance with dame mackie
smith in the great hall
another moment he remembers fondly was
when he had to give a speech he didn't
know the lines to
on the days of the great hall to solve
this the crew ended up putting his lines
on big boards at the end of the hall
so gambin could read off them the late
alan rickman almost dropped out of the
role of snape after the first couple of
films
but a conversation with jk rowling
changed all that
rowling whispered always to rickman and
gave him the backstory he needed in
order to truly master the role
after that conversation rickman would
even assure the directors that he knew
much more about the character than
even they did rickman also enjoyed one
of his final scenes with ray fines in
deathly hallows part 2
where he was able to put down his wand
and just talk
while you live the elder wand cannot
truly
be mine robbie coltrane was gracious to
play such a lovable character in hagrid
after making a career off of playing
hard-edged characters
coltrane's favorite moment occurred in
the sorcerer's stone where norbert the
baby
dragon breeds fire onto hagrid's beard
you have to be trained up a bit of
course
natalia tenna who played hufflepuff
nymphadora tonks said that being able to
fly on a broom
was her favorite part of filming you're
in like this massive
green room on this movable thing and
there's like these two kind of sexy
strong guys
blowing wind at you unlike some of his
fellow cast members
david thulis's favorite scene wasn't one
that he was in
his favorite scene was the opening of
prisoner of azkaban
where harry uses a spell that causes ant
marge to blow up like a balloon
[Music]
jason isaac's favorite scene was one of
the first scenes he ever
shot with richard harrison with young 11
year old daniel
and the day that i realized that i could
wave my hand and doors would shut
the late helen mcrory recalled being in
awe of the final showdown between harry
and voldemort and called it an
extraordinary experience
she said we filmed it in real time it
really happened
and it was a privilege to be there it
was electric
drake
davis has the distinction of playing two
different characters in the franchise
and in the final entry he was able to
reprise both roles as griphook and
professor flitwick
davis appreciated that instead of being
just the comic relief
he actually served a purpose his
favorite onset moment was stage diving
on the set of the yule ball sequence in
the goblet of fire
he revealed that he simply just
suggested the idea as a joke to director
mike newell
but newell liked the idea so much he
went ahead and filmed it
the hogwarts champion cedric dickery
[Applause]
while robert pattinson doesn't have a
particular favorite scene per se
he stated that his favorite aspect of
filming was the familial environment on
set
and that he even felt protected and that
he likely wouldn't still be acting if it
weren't for his role in the franchise
hello ladies love potions eh
yeah they really do work james phelps
said that his favorite scene to film was
the weasley's joke shop scene in the
half-blood prince
he added that the set and production
design was fantastic and he wanted to
show everyone
everything that was there on set oliver
phelps has said that his favorite moment
on set
came while filming the goblet of fire
after taking up director mike newell's
offer to fight him
he had accidentally broken the
director's ribs
what are you doing i'm not doing
anything harry melling's favorite scene
comes from the opening of the order of
the phoenix
i had a lot of fun doing the underpass
stuff with the dementors
just the whole filming of that was very
exciting and and dealing with that
magical element that perhaps
i've never really had before fiona shaw
stated that her favorite scene to film
was when the letters from hogwarts
shot out of the dursley's fireplace in
the first film shaw described that
process as both full of magic but also
very much human nonsense we all tied
them up and put them back in boxes and
we did it again but we all helped
because there were thousands of letters
freddy stroma said that one of his most
memorable days on set
happened while filming a quidditch scene
in the half-blood prince when
he accidentally hit a costume designer
in the head with a quaffle
why are you wearing glasses uh um
reading reading
josh herdman has said that the scene he
remembers the most fondly
is the polyjuice potion scene from
chamber of secrets
he claimed that the producers required
extensive rehearsal time and even made
him sit down and re-watch the first film
in order to capture daniel radcliffe's
likeness
the harry potter cast clearly treasures
their memories from filming
and who wouldn't getting to be a part of
one of the biggest film franchises of
all time
is quite the accomplishment from walking
on set for the first time
to playing guitar with gary oldman or
even scaring the son of the script
supervisor
these were just some of the cast's
highlights which moment in the harry
potter films is your favorite